...
-Xavier Nogueras,
vous êtes un habitué
des dossiers de terrorisme,
vous avez été amené à plaider
aux côtés de la défense
dans le procès
des attentats du Bataclan.
Vous étiez le conseil
de Mohammed Amri,
qui a ramené Salah Abdeslam
en Belgique la nuit des attentats.
Aux yeux de l'opinion,
vous étiez du côté du mal.
Emmanuel Carrère qui a suivi
le procès affirme que,
pour être de ce côté du banc,
il faut aimer se battre.
Vous êtes un pugiliste ?
-Se battre, oui,
d'une certaine manière.
Le combat, il est pas
que dans la violence.
Sur la décennie de terrorisme,
je suis intervenu
sur plusieurs dossiers.
Et j'ai appris.
J'ai appris à défendre
dans ces dossiers-là.
C'est des défenses
qui sont pas communes,
qui sont pas comme dans
tous les dossiers de droit commun.
Parce qu'au final, la réponse,
personne ne l'a.
Ni le juge, ni le procureur,
ni l'avocat.
Et que, quand on touche aux
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation,
on peut pas se positionner
de la même manière.
On doit y aller
avec beaucoup de distance,
beaucoup de mesure,
beaucoup d'humilité.
Et donc moi,
j'ai fait le choix
en montant
sur ce procès-là,
de ne pas y aller
avec la même violence
que dans d'autres dossiers.
Par stratégie aussi
pour celui que je défendais,
mais aussi par respect pour ceux
qui étaient assis dans cette salle.
-On voit ces planches
publiées dans les hors-séries
de Charlie Hebdo, être avocat
dans ce genre d'affaires,
déclariez-vous,
comprend une dimension
à la fois idéologique
et intellectuelle particulière.
Laquelle ?
-Intellectuelle,
parce que c'est une infraction
particulière, l'association
de malfaiteurs.
Dans le box, il y a
plein de gens,
un spectre très différent
selon qu'on se situe du côté droit,
du côté Salah Abdeslam,
ces personnes étaient renvoyées
pour des assassinats
en lien
avec une entreprise terroriste.
Certains sont poursuivis
pour association de malfaiteurs
terroristes.
C'est une défense
qui pousse à la réflexion.
On sait ce qu'est
un viol, un meurtre, un vol,
c'est facile à comprendre.
On sait beaucoup moins
ce qu'est une association
de malfaiteurs.
C'est une infraction qui est
en perpétuelle évolution
et qui a, si vous voulez,
poussé par des querelles
entre les différentes
personnalités,
les procureurs,
les avocats,
les magistrats.
Qui a poussé à réfléchir
et à construire cette matière
dans le temps.
C'est en ça qu'elle
a une dimension intellectuelle.
La dimension idéologique,
c'est qu'il y a des crimes
et des délits en lien
avec le matériel, avec la matière,
il y en a en lien avec l'argent,
il y en a en lien
avec les moeurs,
là, on est en lien
avec l'idéologie.
Les crimes sont commis
au nom d'une idéologie.
Et on ne peut pas rentrer
dans cette matière
sans prendre
en considération cela.
Et essayer
de comprendre les mécanismes,
qui poussent des individus
à commettre l'irréparable.
Il faut avoir une connaissance
sur cette idéologie.
-Qu'avez-vous appris au sortir
de ce marathon judiciaire ?
Ce procès a-t-il
permis d'avancer
sur la compréhension des mécanismes
de radicalisation
et sur la réflexion juridique ?
-Il y a une avancée considérable
grâce à ce procès,
on est tous d'accord
pour se dire
qu'on ne comprend rien
à la radicalisation.
Finalement, c'est pas
le plus important
dans la poursuite
ou la défense de ces individus.
Ca participe pas de
la caractérisation de l'infraction.
-Qu'est-ce qui est
le plus important ?
-C'est le droit.
C'est la traduction juridique
d'un comportement.
Il y a plein de gens
qui ont été poursuivis
dans des dossiers de terrorisme
qui ne faisaient pas partie
de la "djihadosphère",
qui ont été des copains éloignés,
qui ont donné un coup de main
sans...
-En l'occurrence,
comme Mohammed Amri
que vous défendiez.
-Oui.
Je croyais à son innocence
sous le prisme de l'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes.
Il y a plein de gens poursuivis
qui ne sont pas radicalisés,
qui ne l'ont
jamais été
et qui ne le seront jamais.
La radicalisation est
accessoire à tout cela.
La question est
un peu plus subtile.
Vous pouvez ne pas être
radicalisé vous-même,
mais venir en aide
à quelqu'un
en ne pouvant ignorer
sa radicalisation.
-C'était toute la question
du procès.
-Oui.
-En quoi défendre
ces hommes-là est une façon
de lutter contre le terrorisme ?
Je pense,
encore une fois, qu'on a tous
une responsabilité très importante
en qualité
d'auxiliaires de justice.
Il n'y a pas les juges d'un côté,
les avocats, les procureurs,
on porte tous la même robe.
Chaque personne apporte
des réponses à des questionnements
qui permettent de comprendre mieux
le phénomène dans son intégralité.
Je pense.
Et puis surtout parce que
les terroristes cherchent
à détruire l'Etat de droit,
au centre duquel
il y a le processus judiciaire.
Et ce processus judiciaire doit
exister de la même manière
qu'il existait avant
que les fondements de notre société
ne tremblent à cause du terrorisme.
Et c'est une manière de résister.
Le procès,
tel qu'il est organisé aujourd'hui,
avec les temps de parole,
les règles procédurales, après,
il faut évidemment les respecter,
eh bien, cette résistance-là,
c'est une résistance
face au terrorisme.
Parce que je suis
un acteur du procès
en tant qu'avocat de la défense,
j'ai ma place sur les bancs,
je participe à cette résistance et
au maintien du processus judiciaire
et donc c'est une manière de lutter
contre le terrorisme.
-Pourriez-vous dire
que ce procès a été
celui de votre vie ?
-Oui, d'une certaine manière,
par son ampleur,
par les douleurs
de chaque côté de la barre
et parce qu'il peut me permet
de tourner
d'une certaine manière une page
avec une décennie
qui vient de s'achever.
J'ai décidé de lever un peu
le pied sur cette matière-là
et c'est une manière aussi
pour moi de passer aussi
à autre chose.
J'avais besoin d'un événement
et quel meilleur événement
que celui-ci ?
10 mois.
Je souhaite que ça n'arrive plus
jamais évidemment, ça voudrait dire
que quelque chose de terrible
nous est arrivé à nouveau.
-Au cours de ces 10 mois,
avez-vous reçu des lettres
d'insulte, des menaces de mort ?
-Non.
-Parce que l'opinion publique
confond souvent
les avocats et leurs clients.
Les soupçonne de connivence.
-Je crois que ce procès,
cette préparation,
la manière dont tout ça
a été très anticipé,
la communication qui a été
celle de mes confrères,
en amont de ce procès,
a permis aussi, je pense,
et ça, c'est la première chose,
les gens s'intéressent
à notre fonction
et comprennent que nous participons
à un processus.
-Ce procès a contribué
à la compréhension
du rôle des avocats ?
-Oui.
Oui.
-Il vous a un peu dédiabolisés ?
-En tout cas, moi,
ça a été mon objectif
dans la manière
dont j'ai communiqué,
la manière dont je me suis
rapproché d'Arthur Dénouveaux,
victime.
-Survivant du Bataclan.
-Et je...
Et puis, aussi,
peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose
de très lié à ce procès-là,
c'est que les terroristes ont
touché une jeunesse intelligente,
une jeunesse qui avait du recul,
une jeunesse qui était
capable de comprendre.
Quand vous êtes
sur les bancs de la défense,
j'étais tout près de la cour,
donc j'étais à côté de la barre.
Et on a vu défiler ces victimes
pendant 5 semaines.
Quand elles venaient souvent,
ils nous regardaient,
avec d'abord
un regard de défiance,
mais à la fin de leur déposition,
c'était : "Défendez-les.
"Défendez-les.
C'est aussi
pour nous que vous les défendez."
Ca, c'est formidable.
C'est formidable.
Moi, ça a changé complètement
mon regard sur mon métier.
-Justement,
c'était un procès hors-norme
de par son envergure,
le nombre de victimes,
la charge émotionnelle
et sa couverture médiatique.
Ce procès, historique donc,
a-t-il impacté
ou en tout cas modifié
votre façon de plaider ?
-Oui.
La façon d'abord de...
Et je sais, j'ai conscience
que c'est critiqué par un certain
nombre de mes confrères.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-J'ai perdu volontairement
en agressivité.
Ca veut pas dire
que mes arguments
sont moins forts.
En tout cas, j'essaie
de les utiliser
mieux.
-Vous avez gagné en humanité.
-Alors, ce serait
peut-être prétentieux
que je le dise moi-même.
Mais quand je parle
à des acteurs judiciaires,
quand je parle à une cour d'assises
dans cette matière-là,
j'évite d'abord de leur montrer
ou d'essayer de leur montrer
que je connais mieux
le droit qu'eux.
Ca, c'est une catastrophe.
-Vous le faisiez avant ?
-Oui, mais parce que c'est
la jeunesse, l'insouciance,
il y a quelque chose de très
égotique, de très égocentré.
-Vous avez gagné en maturité
au travers de ce procès.
-Je pense qu'il faut
surtout faire comprendre
que je n'ai pas plus
la solution qu'eux.
-La journaliste de France Inter,
Charlotte Piret,
vous a proposé d'échanger
vos impressions à vif tout au long
du procès via des notes vocales
avec elle et Arthur Dénouveaux,
partie civile.
Ce dialogue entre un
survivant, une journaliste et vous
a donné cet étrange et magnifique
journal de bord, qui a été publié,
mais c'était d'abord
des messages vocaux
que vous laissiez
sur un répondeur.
On l'écoute.
*-On est le 20 juin,
*il est 8h53, je suis en train
de partir au palais de justice.
*J'avais envie de vous dire
*que j'en pouvais plus vraiment
de cette audience
*et que je commençais à avoir
une forme de rejet
*de...
*d'overdose, ouais, d'overdose.
*C'est très bizarre
comme sentiment.
*Sentiment comme si tu bouffais
*trop de compote.
*Tu vois ? Forcément, à un moment,
ça devient écoeurant.
*Même si j'adore la compote.
*Je vous embrasse.
-Le 20 juin, vous disiez
même ressentir du dégoût.
C'est fort, le dégoût.
-Non, ça a été très,
très, très compliqué.
C'est tellement long.
On n'est pas préparé à ça.
Un procès, c'est, allez,
2, 3 semaines aux assises.
Parfois même moins.
10 mois, on n'est pas préparés.
Et puis voir
les mêmes personnes.
Ouais.
Voir les mêmes personnes,
voir les mêmes...
Les mêmes...
Les mêmes angoisses.
Les mêmes déceptions.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-On s'est battus.
J'ai un profond respect
pour chacune des personnes
qui ont composé ce procès,
mais on s'est ressentis blessés
dans la défense.
On s'est sentis lésés parfois.
On s'est sentis déséquilibrés.
-Ce procès n'a pas été
conforme au droit ?
-Si.
Avec le recul, je comprends
qu'il y ait eu des moments
de déséquilibre.
Mais je n'irais pas, moi,
jusqu'à dire que c'est un scandale.
C'est une question très complexe.
Ca nous met aussi
en porte-à-faux et en opposition
avec nos confrères.
On était une trentaine d'avocats
de la défense.
C'est assez inédit.
On n'est pas tous d'accord sur
la manière dont se font les choses.
A un moment,
on a tous été d'accord,
et sans se concerter
les uns les autres,
on s'est tous levés
d'un coup et on est partis.
Après, les gens, les avocats
le vivent avec leur expérience,
leur souffrance, leur douleur,
leur mécontentement,
leur positionnement politique.
Peut-être avec du recul que je suis
moins combattif dans cette matière,
parce que ça fait 10 ans et que
c'est un peu la culture de l'échec,
on perd et les gens doivent être
contents de cela.
On perd en terro.
C'est rare.
Il y a pas
d'acquittement ou peu.
Donc on perd.
Et peut-être que c'est aussi
un essoufflement de ma part.
-Il vous est arrivé
de flancher.
Vous est-il
arrivé d'activer la cellule psy
mise en place pendant le procès
ou vous n'y avez pas eu recours ?
-Ma cellule psy, c'était
une bouteille de whisky
à la maison.
J'ai pas de difficulté
à le dire.
C'est aussi en ça
que ça ronge, ce métier.
Il faut être costaud.
Pour...
pour encaisser
toutes ces souffrances et puis
rester le même le lendemain.
Donc quand on rentre le soir,
si on n'est pas fort, qu'on n'a pas
quelqu'un qui nous attend,
on va ouvrir la cellule psy
avec une bouteille d'alcool.
Je sais pas si vous vous...
Enfin, on peut se rendre compte
de l'horreur absolue,
c'est-à-dire que,
contrairement
à d'autres procès,
ils ont été light sur la diffusion
de certaines choses,
mais enfin...
Vous êtes le parent de quelqu'un
qui est mort au Bataclan
et qu'on vous montre
la scène de crime,
les...
les traces de sang
dans la fosse,
les amoncellements de corps,
des membres déchiquetés,
comment est-ce que
vous pouvez rester
normal après tout cela ?
Enfin, je veux dire,
certains ont fermé les écoutilles,
se sont dit, moi, mon rôle,
c'est avocat, je rentre chez moi,
il se passe rien,
moi, même après 10 ans d'expérience
dans cette matière,
j'en suis pas sorti indemne.
-Parlons de votre parcours,
Me Nogueras.
Jawad Bendaoud, le logeur de Daesh,
le terroriste Carlos, l'humoriste
Dieudonné ou le narcotrafiquant
Robert Dawes
ont déjà fait appel
à votre éloquence.
Vous avez également défendu
nombre de radicalisés de retour
de Syrie, les revenants,
comme on les appelle, au point
de vous valoir l'étiquette
d'avocat des djihadistes.
C'est
une appellation non contrôlée.
C'est lourd à porter ?
-Surtout que c'est arrivé
très tôt, ça.
Je défendais, on va dire,
une vingtaine
de revenants de Syrie,
dans les années 2014-2015
et j'ai eu le malheur
de passer sur un plateau de
télévision d'information continue.
-Sur BFM TV en l'occurrence.
-Ils ont mis un bandeau
avec l'avocat des djihadistes.
Ca m'a étiqueté.
Je vais pas
cracher dans la soupe,
c'est ce qui d'une certaine manière
m'a permis de me spécialiser,
non pas dans le djihadisme, mais
dans l'association de malfaiteurs
terroriste.
-Qu'est-ce qui pousse
un secrétaire de la conférence,
la crème de la crème du barreau,
à se spécialiser dans le terro
pour vous citer ?
C'est une ligne de crête
périlleuse.
-Moi, je viens de Grasse,
j'arrive à Paris,
je connais personne,
je connais pas
les noms des avocats,
donc je suis pas pris
dans les cabinets en stagiaire.
Je comprends que le milieu du pénal
est un milieu extrêmement fermé.
Quand je deviens
secrétaire de la conférence...
-La conférence du stage
est une joute
oratoire qui sacre chaque année
les meilleurs rhéteurs
du barreau parisien,
500 candidats, 12 élus,
3 tours, 3 discours.
Comme dans "La nouvelle star",
les candidats doivent embarquer
le jury et des inconnus
se transforment en rock star
pendant un an.
C'est cette rampe de lancement
qui vous a mis sur orbite.
-Oui, je deviens secrétaire
de la conférence en 2013
et c'est le moment où tout explose,
où les gens commencent
à partir en Syrie.
Donc...
Et puis les copains
d'à côté voulaient pas forcément
y aller,
c'était une matière compliquée,
on n'est pas à la 1re génération
de terrorisme,
mais on la connaît pas, nous,
la génération ancienne,
celle de Khaled Kelkal,
celle des attentats de 95,
celle du métro Saint-Michel
ou même
toute la génération 2010.
On regarde ça d'un peu loin
et moi, je me dis que les places
sont chères au pénal,
le stup, c'est fermé,
pour faire des cols blancs,
il faut s'appeler Hervé Temime et
avoir déjà une certaine expérience.
Je suis jeune avocat.
J'ai 2 ans ou 3 ans de barre.
La porte s'ouvre.
Qui n'y va pas ?
Ca, c'est la première chose.
Et puis, mes copains m'ont laissé
un peu la porte ouverte,
ils voulaient pas y aller.
Et puis, je trouve un intérêt,
une satisfaction,
très rapidement,
parce que je rentre dans le monde
de l'idéologie et ça fait écho
à mon histoire familiale.
-Justement,
faut-il chercher dans
votre histoire familiale cabossée
les racines de votre engagement ?
-Oui.
Je pense que c'est la fusion
entre un père et une mère,
un père qui portait la robe,
donc c'est vers là, c'est vers
le droit que je me suis orienté,
et une mère qui a eu une conversion
très puissante et très forte
après la mort de mon père,
une conversion religieuse,
donc une conversion idéologique.
Les deux font que je suis devenu
et pas par hasard, je pense,
avocat
dans la matière idéologique.
Il y a véritablement un sens.
La conversion de quelqu'un
qui vous est proche,
c'est quelque chose
de puissant pour elle,
que vous portez aussi
qui est pas simple.
-Pour l'entourage.
-Pour soi-même aussi,
puisque c'est omniprésent
dans votre cellule familiale.
Et donc Dieu, si vous voulez, est
très présent, a été très présent
dès l'âge de 10 ans.
-Votre père était
juge d'instruction à Grasse.
Il paraît
qu'il arrivait à votre père
de mener ses interrogatoires
avec une grenade à la main.
C'est une légende
ou c'était un trompe-la-mort ?
-C'est pas une légende.
C'est son ami,
qui a été un moment mon mentor
aussi, Jean-Pierre Murciano,
très grand juge d'instruction,
qui a passé toute sa carrière
juge d'instruction à Grasse,
qui a été l'ami de mon père,
ils exerçaient ensemble et qui m'a
montré et appris ce métier,
qui m'a raconté des anecdotes
de mon père.
C'est très important
quand vous êtes enfant, qu'on vous
raconte, pour ne pas fantasmer,
mais matérialiser.
Effectivement, il avait ramené
de l'armée une grenade
et en fait, il s'en servait
juste pour impressionner
quand il interrogeait.
Un jour,
il fait descendre son ami
Jean-Pierre Murciano de l'étage,
il la dégoupille,
elle se met à tourner,
ils se sont barrés
et tout a explosé.
L'ancien tribunal
de grande instance de Grasse.
-Alors, ce papa punk disparaît
alors qu'il n'a pas 40 ans,
sans que vous sachiez
à l'époque ni très bien comment
ni pourquoi.
On évoque
une embolie pulmonaire,
un suicide aussi.
Vous découvrirez le fin mot
de l'histoire bien plus tard
totalement par hasard.
-Oui.
J'avais 9 ans
quand mon père est mort.
Quand notre père est mort.
Et on nous a jamais...
On a essayé de nous préserver
d'une mort qu'assez peu de gens
ont compris finalement.
Parce qu'il avait ses secrets,
il avait ses zones d'ombre.
On savait qu'il y avait
de la drogue, qu'il en consommait,
mais sans qu'on ne veuille
véritablement le voir.
Et j'ai cherché
pendant toute mon adolescence
à essayer de comprendre
pourquoi et comment.
Par hasard,
je vais faire une visite médicale
pour un job d'été
et je tombe sur le médecin légiste
qui, par une faute professionnelle,
que, je pense, il ne se pardonne
toujours pas aujourd'hui,
me dit qu'il a autopsié
le corps d'un juge
des années plus tôt.
Le corps
d'un juge mort, à Grassen
il y en a pas deux,
il y en avait qu'un.
Et donc,
j'ai exigé de connaître les raisons
de la mort de mon père.
Et on a compris
que c'était en lien
avec de la prise de drogues,
peut-être aussi avec une fatigue
psychique et psychologique
qui ont affaibli son organisme
au fur et à mesure.
Il y a pas de cause évidente,
toujours pas.
Ce qu'on retient, c'est que c'était
un homme formidable, très aimant,
qui aimait énormément
ses enfants, qui est parti
trop tôt et ça,
on lui en veut évidemment.
C'est compliqué quand quelqu'un
part et que vous êtes aussi jeune.
Vous avez une maman
qui doit tout gérer seule.
Et...
-Y compris des violences sexuelles
de la part d'un proche,
qui se solderont
par une condamnation à 18 ans
de réclusion criminelle.
Votre soeur est
devenue commandant
de police, vous, avocat
votre frère, réalisateur,
ce que l'on pourrait résumer
par cette trinité : l'ordre,
la justice et la transcendance.
-Ca me plaît beaucoup
cette trilogie-là.
Et est-ce que, finalement,
ce n'est pas totalement
à l'image du couple qu'était
celui de mon père et de ma mère ?
On a eu effectivement
une succession de drames
dans notre famille,
mais justement,
la résilience est
un mot important
qui caractérise l'évolution
de ces trois enfants-là.
On n'a jamais voulu
se laisser faire.
Et la réussite de mon frère,
je la trouve admirable.
Je suis très en admiration.
Ma soeur est
une personne incroyable
qui aujourd'hui se bat
pour des principes
qui sont les siens
et qui sont aussi admirables.
La leçon qu'il faut en tirer, c'est
que, ouais, malgré les drames,
qui jonchent
le parcours de vos vies,
il faut continuer
à croire en vos idées
et se battre pour arriver
à des objectifs.
Et je trouve que tous les trois,
nous y sommes arrivés.
-Comme Hervé Temime
ou Eric Dupond-Moretti,
vous pensez qu'il faut
des failles narcissiques
pour être pénaliste ?
-Je pense que,
pour être pénaliste,
en tout cas, j'estime moi, avoir
toutes les failles narcissiques,
parce que, effectivement,
quand vous perdez quelqu'un jeune,
vous avez un besoin
de reconnaissance.
Il y a une sorte
d'incompréhension
qui va se traduire en un besoin
de reconnaissance absolu,
vous le trouvez souvent
dans des activités théâtrales.
Vous vous mettez en avant,
qu'on me regarde,
que la lumière soit sur moi.
Et quel meilleur métier
que le métier d'avocat
pour soigner ces failles-là ?
Vous parlez, on se tait.
Ce besoin de reconnaissance
absolu qui est
nécessairement lié
à la perte de mon père,
je réussis à le soigner
dans mon activité
professionnelle.
-J'aimerais revenir
sur le procès
des attentats du Bataclan.
Ce n'est jamais
facile de juger un verdict,
que dire de la perpétuité
incompressible,
la sanction la plus lourde
du droit français ?
L'ancien Garde des Sceaux,
Robert Badinter, est opposé
à une peine qui équivaut
à une mort lente.
Et vous ?
-Je suis d'accord.
Cette décision
est extrêmement violente.
Quel que soit...
Quel que soit le crime commis.
La détention,
c'est 22 heures sur 24
dans une cellule
de 9 mètres carrés.
22 heures sur 24 !
Dans des conditions
que l'on sait particulièrement
indignes en France.
C'est pas moi qui le dis.
C'est dit par des confrères
qui sont des confrères spécialisés.
C'est reconnu.
On est condamnés par la Cour
européenne des Droits de l'Homme.
22 heures sur 24, 2 heures sur 24,
quand vous êtes à l'isolement,
ce qui est le cas
pour la plupart d'entre eux
dans une petite cour
avec un grillage.
Et cela, toute votre vie ?
Toute votre vie ?
-Comment redescend-on,
Me Nogueras,
après avoir pris part
à un tel procès ?
-Moi, j'ai eu besoin
de me retrouver
dans ma maison à Grasse, notre lieu
de rassemblement familial,
qui était la maison de mon père.
Mais les cigales
et l'herbe fraîche et...
Et...
L'odeur des pins et la pierre,
ça n'a pas suffi
à redescendre.
Il y a eu des animosités,
il y a eu des querelles,
des conflits,
des déceptions avec ce procès.
Il y a eu plein de choses.
C'est le burn-out.
Affectivement,
les choses vont pas forcément bien,
vous êtes en colère,
donc vos relations avec vos proches
ne fonctionnent pas,
vous redescendez très lentement.
Un été dans le noir.
-Et aujourd'hui ?
-Après, ça va...
Il faut refaire des choses, il faut
remonter à cheval, comme on dit.
-Vous allez continuer
dans le terro ?
-Ceux dans lesquels
je suis encore avocat,
je vais aller au bout.
-Et ensuite ?
-C'est terminé,
je passe à autre chose.
Il y a plein d'autres choses
passionnantes.
-J'aimerais conclure
avec cette phrase
de Me Jean-Marc Delas :
"La justice,
c'est dominer la haine."
-Elle a plein de sens,
cette phrase.
La justice,
c'est dominer la haine,
c'est ce que je vous disais,
c'est déjà pour le juge juger
non pas avec son ventre,
mais avec sa tête.
Juger avec son ventre,
ça donne des décisions bancales,
des décisions déséquilibrées.
Et au final,
c'est des décisions
qui ne satisfont ni la défense
ni les parties civiles.
La justice, peut-être aussi
pour les parties civiles,
c'est savoir pardonner.
Enfin, en tout cas,
remettre ce qu'on a en soi
entre les mains
d'une tierce personne
qui donnera justice.
La justice,
c'est dominer la haine,
quand on est avocat,
c'est dominer la colère qu'on peut
avoir de la contradiction
du contradicteur
qui ne nous comprend pas
et estimer que c'est nous
qui avons raison.
A justice,
elle est faite ensemble.
On est là pour protester
quand ça va pas,
mais on n'a pas toujours raison
et eux tort.
Elle est multifaces, cette phrase,
mais très intelligente.
-Merci, Xavier
Nogueras.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...